like working with young zombies Tilda
Swinton and how much fun did you have
making a vampire movie you know Jim is
as a completely unique voice in cinema
and it was a pleasure this is such a
pleasure to work with him he has he has
a huge wit and warmth and a knowledge
and wisdom about all kinds of things
music and poetry and literature and
working with him working Matilda on this
was a pleasure yeah yeah I mean it's
sort of it's not really a vampire movie
in terms of what you might expect it's
more of a film about too sophisticated
and mysterious Outsiders who are in love
and they live forever so how does their
love change with their own mortality Jim
Jarmusch's is a rock star and he's
there's no one like him in cinema he's
got a very very particular distinctive
taste a whipped knowledge about music
and an art and and this film is so full
of his wisdom and his knowledge and only
lovers left alive is really from about
love and it's quite hard to describe but
I just know that you've never seen a
vampire film like
I don't I can't think of a film where
there's two vampires called Adam and Eve
who Rockstar poets holed up in Detroit
in Tangier and this is that fun it's a
love story that's all I would say it's a
love story about about these two
mysterious creatures of the night who
happen to live forever so yeah I guess
if you're curious to see that then then
come and see it whenever I make a new
film it always feels like a new
adventure it never feels like I'm I'm
using things from other things I've done
in Ascenta Kirillov it is that we're
setting out on some on on a new journey
and learning new things I've never
played a musician before my character in
this film Adam is a musician he plays
the guitar he plays the violin who plays
the lute and also I've never made a film
about love in this way so truly is a
film about love and acceptance and these
two cat my character and tildes
character are two kind of delicate
refined and nocturnal creatures who
happen to live forever and therefore how
does their how does the nature of their
love change over time you'll be playing
coral either this year what is it about
that character that attracted Leigh you
know it's a it's a fascinating character
because he's a soldier
corralled into politics and and really
the tension and the drama comes from
that conflict your father sent a request
they acting adore your impressions and
they are desperate to see you do samuel
l.jackson doing okay I think he'd have
an issue with that given that he plays a
Marvel character himself I don't know
how you play it he'd be like what we say
he'd be like mm I am Loki of Asgard and
burden but Laura's [ __ ] purpose
that's what he'd say
you